so now we are going to look at the main
line and that is the move e5 well
against FIFA blacks should certainly
play the move d5 so counter-attacking
this bishop and again the main line is
Bishop to b5 but instead of Bishop to b5
let's look what happens when white
capture this night so e cross F six D
cross C for an e cross g7 black has to
play the move rook to g8 although it
looks bit scary but this line is very
very good for black the simple reason is
black has this wonderful center and that
turns out a big asset for the black
perspective so here there are a few
moves has been tried and the first game
my opponent try the move Bishop to at
six but this is a useless move because I
played the move Queen to f6 immediately
attacking the bishop
that means White has to do something
with the bishop so first of all my
opponent tried this Queen check and
after I block with the bishop he is
pointed with the move Bishop to g5 here
black can simply capture this pawn and
again there are two moves has been tried
so in the first game my opponent try to
castle on the King side but after a very
simple d3 attacking the Queen and Queen
to e4
like responded with the moon at 6:00 and
my opponent find is hotter that he
cannot move his bishop because the mate
is threatened on g2 so white lose a
piece and so as the game so instead of
cash laying the another move tried has
been is g3 so stopping the mate idea but
now once again black and play the move
at 6:00 and after Bishop to h4 which has
an idea that it's not allowing black to
castle on the Queen side but
nevertheless I can continue with the
move
d3 attacking the Queen and after Queen
to e4 that can go for this wonderful
Queen trade that is Queen to g6 and this
gives black a wonderful game
my opponent continuous with the move
Knight B to d2 but after Queen captures
and Knight recaptures I played the move
Bishop to e7 so blocking the file and
planning to castle on the Queen side and
hear my opponent played this blunder
move that is Knight to f6 check
before we go on I give you a few seconds
can you identify a winning sequence from
the black perspective
I hope you find this one which is Bishop
takes f6 and after Bishop takes
black can simply play the move Bishop to
defy and as far as I can see white will
lose a piece
the more aggressive reply over here is
immediately Bishop to g5 but against
this black and play the move f6 and the
whole idea of Bishop to g5 to throw this
check which is Queen to e2 check but
here black can simply play Queen to e7
and give away the f6 pawn the game
continues like this so my opponent take
this pawn now I exchange the Queen and
after King recapture I played the move
Bishop to g4 so pinning the night so my
opponent reinforced tonight with Knight
B to d2 here I continue with my
initiative so I played the move d3 and
after King to have fun I capture the f3
Knight and after white we capture hit
that Bishop with King to have seven here
black retrieve the bishop to the h4 and
then black we gain the pawn with King
cross g7 so we have the imbalance in the
pawn structure but if you look at
carefully black has a tremendous pawn
sitting on d3 which can be a great asset
in this variation so the game continues
like this so my opponent tried look to
even but after rook g2e wait
my opponent played the move Bishop to g3
which allows me to gain a big advantage
first of all capture this rook with a
check and
turkeying captures I give this another
check with the rook and after King to d1
finally my rook has been posted on the
seventh rank that is rook to e2
look at the activity of their troop
compared to the passive look of the
white and no wonder black has a
tremendous advantage
the thought of this move which I want to
consider is the castle on the Kings side
but after this I can simply capture this
G pawn and again in this game my
opponent try the move rook to even check
and after Bishop to e6
he played the move Bishop to f4 so in a
way white is trying to tell off his
pieces here I played the move Queen to
d7 II now my opponent played a very
cunning move that is Bishop to g4 so he
wants to stop me to castle on the Queen
side but now I can respond with the move
D 3 so gaining space on the Queen side
and after Knight B to d2 I drop my
bishop back to the e7 so blocking the
file and ready to castle on the Queen
side so my opponent tried the move
Bishop takes a 7 and after Queen takes
c7 he thought that he came a valuable
pawn after Knight takes e4 of course
black deliberately sacrifice a pawn to
get his King to a safety and that's why
after Knight takes e4 black castle on
the Queen side and the game continues
like Knight to e4 afterwards black
responded with the move Queen to d6 hear
my opponent exchange one night so he
captured my night on the c6 and after I
recaptured he played the move rook to e3
but now you see the amazing potential of
that vital passport so here I played the
move
d - please note that night cannot
capture this pole because at the end
there is a mate on g2 so my opponent has
to desperately try the move g3 but that
creates the another problem that is
black and play the move Bishop to g4
so pinning that night and asking why to
find a good move well in the game my
opponent after long thinking come out
with this only move that is the move
ash3
but after very simple Bishop captures
Knight and Roop captures Bishop black
can play the move rook to e8 and as far
as I can see the game is almost lost
the final move played was rook to e3 but
now the task you become very easy for
black because that can simply capture
this rook and after white recaptured
black will give this check and white
King will not survive longer
so this analysis give you enough
confidence to meet the move across f6 so
let's look at the main line that is
Bishop to b5
so instead of E cross F six at this
point the main line is Bishop to b5 here
black should continue with the move
Knight to e4 allowing by to regain his
phone so C cross d4 but afterwards black
will play the move Bishop to b6 and in
fact this is the starting position of
the main line
now as you can see I have highlighted by
the arrows black is attracting to play
the move Bishop to g4 which will make
the d4 pawn beaker so white has to
reinforce the d4 pawn with the move
Bishop to e3 and now black will castle
on the King side and after White Castle
on the Queen side
please remember this move which give you
a slight advantage and that is the move
f5 and here I have three games for you
so in the first game my opponent ride
across f6 and I recapture with Knight
now my opponent played the move Queen to
c2 so here I responded with the move
Queen to b6 afterwards White has tried
to Knighton's so in the first game my
opponent tried Knight B to d2 but then
black should continue with the move
Bishop to d7 and after Bishop captures
Queen captures Queen captures and Bishop
captures black has this wonderful bishop
pair and why it has a problem because it
has an isolated pawn in another game my
opponent tried Knight to c3 at this
point and that is more nation move but
that allows black to get a huge
advantage so here black should play the
move Knight to g4 which has a very
cunning idea that black wants to capture
this Knight and then made the white on
h2 and to illustrate how dangerous this
is let me show you one game which can be
a very lethal so at this point my
opponent tried the move H free but now I
capture this Knight with the rook and
white cannot cap this rook because this
key will be mated on h2 so white has to
capture this night afterwards black has
this fantastic shot Knight takes d4
attacking the white queen so that means
Y response is pretty much force white
has to take this Knight you now black
will capture the special
and it turns out that black will remain
upon up in the situation
funny enough that my opponent was 2000
plus and he didn't understand how
dangerous this is and he decided to
capture this rook which allows me to
mate him instantly so I played the move
Queen to g3 check and please note this
f2 coin is pinned right now so white has
to forcefully go to the h1 afterwards
Queen will capture the f3 Pole
I'll give you an exercise for you there
is a mate in nine so pause the video and
find out checkmate in nine moves
okay so I'm showing right now after King
2g1
Queen captures g4 check and after King
to edge to Queen to a5 check White King
dance will continue with the MU King to
g2 but now black has a fantastic shot
which is Bishop to h3 check and that
will finish the game outright because
White has to forcefully capture this
Bishop afterwards Queen to f3 check King
to h2 and Bishop to e5 check will leads
to a very quickly so let me go through
this moves very very quickly King to g1
Queen to g4 check
King to h1 twin twist recheck and final
moves are king to g1 and queen - to
checkmate
in another game my opponent try the move
Bishop takes c6
and after a black recapture my opponent
played the MU g3 as you can see I have
highlighted by the arrows black is
threatening to play the more f4 so he
played the move g3 and he thought that
and I'm stopping therefore but can you
guess yeah black will play the move for
and the funny thing is white cannot
capture with the bishop because if white
captured with the bishop then white will
lose a piece after very simple-looking
the MU G Phi if Bishop drop backs now
then Bishop to g4 will never piece
so at this point where it has to
forcefully capture with the gee-pole so
G cross f4 but now black can pin that
night with the move Bishop to g4 and
this is a very awkward move to meet
because the normal-looking move looks
like Knight B to d2 but it turns out a
big mistake because now black can
capture this knight with his own night
and now Queen cannot recapture that
night and if Bishop captures Knight then
white will lose a vital pawn on d4 so
that is all you need to know in the
Scotch
gambit mainline it's time to look at the
side variations